a voyage to eavesdrop on a hidden
submarine soundscape the south coast of
ireland is home to an abundance of
whales
including huge fin whales and humpbacks
in the summer
but there are also busy shipping lanes
and ship strikes are a significant and
underreported danger to whale
populations
now a new monitoring project could help
this boy launched nine kilometers off
the county court coast
as a smart hydrophone that will listen
in on the area's
many sea mammals in real time
these waters are absolutely teeming with
wildlife so far just on this short trip
we've seen a minke whale
common dolphins and gray seals and the
researchers on this vessel hope that
they can learn new ways to protect these
intelligent species
by using artificial intelligence
the acoustic data will be used to train
machine learning models
to identify different species calls and
ultimately could create a real-time
detection system
we know very little about the rate of
ship strike in irish waters and how
often waves are hit by ships
um but we also know very little about
you know how
loud our ships are arc ireland has had
an observers off since 2017
so what we hope to do is to integrate um
or acoustics
and detections and the real-time
information coming through into the app
and then that can pop up and it can
notify mariners that there is a
potential whale in the area
so what they can do is they can reduce
their speed and then that will limit the
impact of noise pollution but it will
also reduce the risk of ship strike
apart from the scientific reward derived
from the new technology
mariners here hope the project will help
raise public awareness
what's really important about it is that
and this is something that we do as
boat operators as well is to be aware
that
what we do also affects the animals but
it's to make the general public aware
that these animals are out there number
one but to also respect them when we do
vote or not to disturb them and not to
upset them
this is like it's one of the good news
stories in the midst of a pandemic where
everything seems to be negative
good news for the whales good news for
the for the wildlife yeah absolutely
from the ocean to the cloud ai and data
analysis could be
key to allow marine mammals and commerce
exist side by side stephen murphy sky
news
off the court coast